Now we have the slides up for um Dr.
Orit Gal. She and specializes her
research is about strategy and
complexity. And what's really
interesting uh we met uh went up here
and and discussed as well is that she's
going to talk about urban sermpidity
which is ultimately about the vibe and
as she told me and I find that really
interesting. Dr. Gal is coming from
outside of our community, really a
newbie in in our community, not in her
field obviously. And um and and she Amy
Hodler was actually um one of our my
co-chairs um was telling her, "You
should come. Please come." Um and I
think you you're interested in just
networking with the community and
finding out in uh the ways that finding
out about our work and how that could
help with this urban development. And as
we saw from this um previous um talk,
that's exactly it like it's it's a
network. Urban spaces are full of
networks and and the the graph
technology makes a lot of sense and it's
a good match. So without further ado, I
would like to introduce our last
speaker, Dr. Oral. Um and you can then
go ahead.
>> Thank you so much. Uh thank you so much
for having me. It's really exciting. Um,
as was mentioned, I am not a graph
expert in any way. Uh, I'm not a data
scientist. Um, and I've been kind of
walking these rooms for the last two
days like a really curious alien trying
to see overlaps and how hopefully you
guys can help me solve some problems and
turn some more conceptual stuff into
really operational uh, innovations. Um
so my expertise is in complexity led
strategic design which is really about
analyzing loads of micro trends uh
political, economic, technological and
cultural pulling them together depending
on the context and identifying
opportunities, gaps, shifts that are
coming our way. And for the last seven
years, a lot of my work both from an
entrepreneurial perspective and from an
academic perspective focus on the future
of cities. And when you think about what
is the environment in which we all live
and not just us another billion and a
half people are going to move into
cities over the next decade and a half.
What will it actually look like? And
when you try to think about that, you
look at two things. You look at the
actual trends. what is changing in terms
of how we work and how we live uh and
our culture and our institutions and
also what is the essence what will
always remain the same. What is the
essence of the city? What is the point?
Why did we evolve cities in the first
place? And of course a city is a really
great social mixer. This is what it
does. This is why we evolved to live in
cities. It is all about our abilities to
scale networks. We bring together loads
of strangers from many many different
areas and just by the fact of density we
create amazing opportunities and scale
and Jeffrey West uh has led if you know
the Santa Fe Institute uh work on the
maps of cities and how cities scale. Uh
and of course what is very interesting
is that city scale in super linear
formations which means that when you
double the size of a city you more than
double its innovation its wealth and
loads of other variables and this really
helps us explain why we evolve to live
in bigger and bigger cities to begin
with. So the city itself is really us.
As Jeffrey West says, it is simply the
manifestation of its underlying social
network. Which means that a thriving
city by definition needs to have a
resilient network, needs to have a
network that on the one hand has
stickiness. So we do have continuous
interactions with different nodes if you
like. But there's also a sense of
freedom in terms of association and
accessibility to those networks. And the
question is how does that actually work?
And one of the key mechanisms when you
try to understand how that works in a
very self-organized spontaneous way, it
is really about serendipity. It is all
about random collisions. So another way
to think about the city is a network uh
property that is on constant discovery
mode right we cannot do anything on our
own any action is an interaction and
therefore we're constantly looking
consciously subconsciously to connect
with other people to have access to
everything that is flowing within those
networks and what is actually flowing
are really three things. It is all about
resources. It is information and it is
behavior. And what you see at the macro
level is economies of elomeration. Which
means that when people collaborate,
compete and are able to observe others
in close physical proximity, you have
much higher productivity.
And the question is how does that uh
actually thrive? What are the underlying
conditions?
So for thousands of years, all of this
worked really well and we didn't really
need to think about it at all. It just
happened. And it just happened because
we were strangers and we were brought
into a city and we collided with other
people and we needed other people for
loads of everyday things. The thing is
when you look at current trends, so many
of those trends seem to converge on one
key element which is the gradual removal
of friction within our urban
environments and this is all due to
wonderful technology. I mean the whole
point of technology is really to remove
frictions, right? It is to create much
smoother interactions. It is to make
things more efficient and faster. So I
don't need to go to my neighbor and ask
if I can borrow an egg, right? That
would seem weird. Uh I can just, you
know, go to the corner shop or better
yet just order it online and it'll be in
my home in 15 minutes. Uh I'm not going
to ask anyone for directions anymore
because I have a phone. Um I don't smoke
anymore, so I'm not going to ask you for
a light. uh all of these small friction
points that used to exist as a kind of
entrylevel
sociability are gradually removed. And
these are all side effects. But the
problem is if serendipity is really a
fundamental mechanism in terms of how
cities and if you like humanity thrives
then what happens when we actually
remove it and how can we actually um
reintroduce it into the environment.
Because again when we look at trends uh
and we start to connect you to different
social, psychological and economic
trends, we see again trends that repeat
themselves everywhere in the world. It's
not about culture. It's not about
geography. It is literally about the
size of a city. Uh and everywhere we
find the urban loneliness epidemic uh
happening. And again, the bigger the
city, the lonier people get. Uh so it
really follows the same kind of super
linear scaling. Um interestingly it's
not your 80-year-old neighbor. I mean
you know he might be lonely as well but
it it is actually millennials uh and Gen
Z's who are the lonliest who are the
loneliest. And actually it got to such a
stage that the World Health Organization
um has put a huge emphasis and a huge
project on this for the next five years
and they actually loneliness with
smoking 15 cigarettes a day which is
kind of ironic given that you know if we
smoked before we were more sociable but
the question is what do we do with that?
So on the tech side uh there are a lot
of people who are trying to figure out
whether we can do any social matchmaking
and by the way some of the dating apps
have gone into that as well. But we find
that actually connecting people to
become friends is much more complex than
creating romantic uh matching. So that
doesn't really work. And if you think
about all the friends that you have in
your life and all the connections that
you've had, these are gradual processes
with so many little moments and again
serendipity and unended
um elements that are just part of that
story. Another problem um is again our
own evolutionary brains. And here the
problem is that we are just afraid to
connect with other people. especially in
terms of strangers when there is no
actual excuse to talk to them. So
research shows that even though almost
all of us say that we would love to talk
to strangers, we assume that less than
half of them want to talk to us back. So
there's a fundamental gap here in terms
of our fear of rejection. Now when you
need something, if you need to ask
someone for directions, then that's
fine. You have a legitimate excuse and
Somehow that fear of rejections is cast
aside. But what happens when you no
longer need people? Is there something
else that we can introduce?
So the gist of it is really if we don't
find ways to reignite our social
mechanisms, what we're going to end up
with is living in very dense
environments. We're talking about mega
cities that are just going to explode
across the globe. But they will be very
sterile and we will lose the mechanisms
that actually pull us together. We will
just you know be confined to very
crowded spaces and you can think about
the dystopian visions that that can
create.
So the question is can we move into
another logic that actually works with
our monkey brains and everything that is
happening in around us in terms of
technology and economics and can we move
from needs which is one side of
legitimate interactions into playfulness
which is another side of legitimate
interaction. So people seem to feel at
ease if there is something that is
playful, that is inviting in the area,
that is another excuse to talk with
people around them, not just if they
need each other.
So if you think about again serendipity
as unintentionally finding resources
around you, the question is could we
actually design our environment in a way
that could increase the probability of
these random collisions? Could we create
an ambiencece, a vibe if you like that
invites people uh to connect in whole
new ways and put aside the fear of
rejection. So I've been working on these
issues from two perspectives. One is the
micro uh perspective uh which is all
about working with um designers such as
uh Rob
and um and a behavioral expert named
Rosinski and we're trying to see if we
could uh iterate with different social
puzzles and different whimsical physical
elements that we can introduce into
different public spaces whether it's
conferences or museums or big you know
public squares to get people to interact
more but what I'm hoping to get help
from you guys today is on the macro side
and that is about how we can analyze the
environment itself in a new way and
understand what is it within certain
environments that are just more
inviting. So could we use data to
analyze vibe?
Now vibe is really a distinctive emotion
that we just all sense when we go into a
place. So it's not about the coolness.
Uh it's not about the certain specific
vibe. is really about an emotion and
that emotion is an emergent property. It
means that it is something that exists
only at the systemic level and you
cannot really identify it at the unique
level. It emerges out of what everyone
does and that is kind of the magic and
the beauty of it. And again as humans we
are able to interpret these type of
emotions quite quickly. So you can about
different types of vibes in public
spaces. Uh so on the social side, you
have an energetic vibe. So you might go
into a marketplace or a place that has
music or something is happening, you
know, happy streets we like to hang out
in and we immediately sense that there
is something friendliness and open about
it and therefore people are more willing
to interact. Or it could be the other
way around. It could be just completely
chilled like a great day in Hamstead
Heath when the sun is out and it's not
freezing like today. Uh and again that
is another type of setting where people
really feel at ease and are much more
willing to playfully interact with one
another. And of course on the not so
social side we have places that just
feel unsafe, right? We sense that
immediately or places that just kind of
feel standoffish like really snobbish
and again you wouldn't want to kind of
feel comfortable interacting with
anyone. So if we can sense that
immediately intuitively as humans can
that be translated in some way into data
so we can analyze different spaces along
those lines. So for example, if you
think about the data sources themselves,
there are CCTVs everywhere like all the
public spaces are being observed in any
case, especially in London. So can we
actually use for example video and audio
data in public spaces to discern their
socialability by are these places more
sociable or less sociable? So on the one
hand there's loads of data but then the
question is how do you start to analyze
it and what are you actually looking
for?
Now, of course, the purpose of this is
not just to say that this has a great
vibe or this doesn't, but actually to
use it as a means to constantly improve
and iterate